how do you convert bytes to a string in
Python is one of the most asked most
upvoted most viewed questions on stack
Overflow and what better way to hack the
algorithm than to answer a question
that's already been answered a thousand
times before
so welcome to M coding I'm James Murphy
let's talk about strings bytes why
they're different and how to convert
between them
strings and bytes look very similar in a
number of ways in Python you can make a
string literal between quotes and just
add a b in front to make it a bytes
literal you can also use single quotes
for either one or single or double
triple quotes
they both support Escape sequences like
backslash n to make a new line and they
both support putting an r in front to
ignore Escape sequences one difference
is that there are F strings that allow
you to interpolate variables into
Strings but you can't do F bytes but
that's a pretty small difference and the
types have a huge number of functions in
common here I'm calling der to give me
all the attributes of the string and
bytes types I convert those to sets and
then use the Ampersand to get the set
intersection and then print them out and
they have so many different things in
common everything from addition to
finding replacing ripping splitting
partitioning they both seem to have most
of the traditional string functions
replace the Ampersand with a minus to
see the functions that string has but
bytes doesn't and it's really just a few
and swap bytes and string here to see
just the bytes functions that string
doesn't have
there's literally just four functions
but in spite of offering such similar
functionality python seems to make a
point of keeping them very separate if I
open a file in text mode I have no
trouble writing strings but trying to
write bytes will result in an error if I
wanted to write those bytes I'd have to
call the code to get a string and then
write that
if I open the file in binary mode then I
can only write bytes this time
attempting to write a string will give
me an error but if I wanted to get this
ring I would just call in code to get
equivalent bytes and then write that
so if strings and bytes are so similar
why is python insistent on keeping them
so separate
and what's the difference between them
anyway strings are just made up of bytes
after all right
well yes and no to see the difference
let's take a look at a smiley face
but first a message from this video
sponsor
me
in all my years of working with myself I
can say I truly recommend my own
services
my team does Python and C plus plus
Consulting Contracting training and
interview prep if you have a project
that you'd like to get some outside eyes
on check out emcoding.io and reach out
to me anyway back to Strings and bytes
hmm is a smiley face a character well
when I run this function it appears like
it is it seems to act like any other
character I can print it just fine and
python says that there's just one
character in the string
but if we try to do the same thing with
a bytes literal it doesn't allow us
it tells us we can only use ASCII
literal characters
okay well instead let's try encoding the
string to convert it to bytes and then
printing that backslash X is an escape
sequence to give a hexadecimal number
two hex letters is 16 times 16
possibilities which is 256.
otherwise known as one byte
so that means that the encoded form of
the smiley face contains four bytes
we can even Loop over the bytes object
to see what the four numbers are
in particular although the length of the
string was one the length of the bytes
is four
and while we're at it how do we know
that these four bytes correspond to a
smiley face
after all they're just four bytes in
memory how do we know that they don't
actually correspond to the integer made
up of those bytes
or we could interpret those four bytes
to get yet another integer that those
bytes represent or maybe there's some
kind of floating Point number or a
32-bit pointer
how do we know what those bytes actually
mean
the answer is that a sequence of bytes
on its own doesn't carry any meaning
if I just gave you a sequence of bytes
there are an infinite number of
possibilities for what they could mean
it's completely up to you to determine
what the bytes mean
and that is the reason that string and
bytes are different
strings are made up of characters a
smiley face the letter A the number
seven these are things that have meaning
to us outside of computers but of course
anything that we actually store on a
computer does ultimately have to get
translated into ones and zeros so a
bytes object is meant to store a raw
sequence of bytes as it would be stored
in memory but a string stores an
interpretation of those bytes in terms
of characters so when I ask python to
decode a bytes object I'm telling python
this isn't just random memory this is a
sequence of characters tell me what
these bytes mean if you were to
interpret them as characters
but there's still a piece of the puzzle
missing who determined that these
numbers mean smiley face
and that these numbers mean ABCD
this is the job of What's called the
encoding
that's encoding not M coding
the encoding is a bi-directional map
that gives you the sequence of bytes
that corresponds to every character
if you don't specify the encoding python
will use the default which is utf-8
utf-8 is by far the most common encoding
across all programming languages at the
time of recording it has upwards of 97
Mark share
it's a worldwide standard about how to
interpret bytes as characters or more
specifically what they refer to as code
points and the name stands for Unicode
transformation format 8-bit commonly
referred to just as Unicode it was
developed as an extension of the very
popular ASCII encoding so that we could
include more characters like letters
from many different languages
and of course everybody's favorite
emojis
but even though ugf8 is by far the most
common there are other encodings and
this can be a huge source of frustration
in Python by default encoding a string
into bytes or decoding a string from
bytes will use ugf8 if you don't specify
the encoding
but when reading and writing files it'll
actually use the system encoding by
default which on my machine is not utf-8
so if I try to write something that has
a smiley face in it
then I get an error
I can fix this issue by explicitly
specifying the encoding now when I write
the file and read it back everything
works
not specifying the encoding can also be
an issue if you write the file on one
computer that has one default encoding
and then try to read it on another
computer that has a different encoding
let's say I wrote it as utf-8 but tried
to read it as this second most popular
encoding
very unfortunately I don't get an
exception in this case I just get a
string with garbage on the end
this is one of the worst classes of
Errors to run into because aside from
printing things out I won't have any
indication that anything is wrong and
now I may be feeding this garbage data
into other functions which could result
in wrong things being displayed to my
user or potentially bad data being fed
into a calculation
if I switch to yet another encoding this
would be the luckier case where it
actually detects that something is wrong
so what I recommend is if there's an
option to specify encoding just always
specify it and use utf-8 unless you have
a really good reason not to
if you're using python 310 or later you
can run python with this Dash X warn
default encoding
doing so will run your program as normal
except it will also print out an
encoding warning anytime you forget to
specify your encoding
alternatively in python37 and later you
could run with the utf-8 flag
this will basically make python treat
utf-8 as your default encoding even if
it's not
and fun fact look up pep 686
this is an already accepted pep that's
going to make utf-8 the default in
Python
the only catch is that it's scheduled to
become the default not in Python 312 not
in 313 not in 314 but in three 15. so
put that on your Christmas list
anyway I hope this has cleared up the
difference between strings and bytes for
you a bytes object just represents a
literal sequence of bytes in memory with
no interpretation
whereas a string uses an encoding like
utf-8 to interpret those bytes as a
sequence of actual characters
don't forget to slap that like button
leave a comment and subscribe
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me